hey guys Ryan right over here okay so a  20-second trailer for Batman vs Superman  dawn of Justice literally just dropped I  immediately turn on my camera I have to  check this out and normally don't check  out previews to previews but it's Batman  versus Superman  right  if it shows [ __ ] but just seeing like  the image of the two costumes is so  [ __ ] cool to me thank you guys all  are you for telling me that I'll make  sure to do a full trailer review of the  actual trailer when it drops I'll be  doing a reaction to that too if you're  new to the channel you can subscribe to  the real rejects and you can follow us  on Facebook Instagram and Twitter  oh my god I cannot wait for this trailer  to drop the second it drops I'm filming  it yeah  my balls are tingling with excitement  right now